let's get to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 57 1 7 is the area code of our next
caller caller from 7 1 7 who's this
what's on your mind hey David it's
Calvin the hurricane dude Calvin the
hurricane okay go ahead what's on your
mind
the hurricane no I mean the guy who was
like you know was fantasizing over a
chumps resort and blowing away right
right yeah what can we do for it um look
I'm doing David Pakman puzzle pieces you
mean like an actually like a 500 piece
David Pakman show puzzle yeah like based
on like a couple images from like you
know old school Pakman show and like
your new uh your your hatred mail
calendar and whatnot that's pretty
brilliant actually yeah we could take
the David Pakman show 2018 calendar
cover image right I'm sure there's a
service online where you upload an image
and say I want this to be a 500 or a 750
piece sir puzzle and we could offer the
puzzles for free with memberships or
something like that or we could make it
like our next Jenga gimmick where we try
to raise funds on patreon that's a
little more complicated we add a piece
for every contribution to it yeah that's
an interesting one but I like this idea
do you know actually I can probably the
the people that make our calendar can
probably do this but is there a
suggested provider Calvin that you might
suggest for that idea I don't know but
like I'm gonna have look into it like
[Music]
please email in if you find one that's a
good idea Calvin will look into that
that could be a cool thing David Pakman
show puzzle I free with membership or
something like that yeah all right very
good
thanks Calvin appreciate the call just
calling in with an idea I love that